you know brad and i are our buddies
remember this hi anderson hi pitt
how you doing good honey how are you
doing i'm all right
yeah the internet pretty much lost it
when jennifer aniston and brad pitt
reunited for the fast times at richmond
high table read last year and now the
actress is speaking out about it
no no problem absolutely fun
you know brad and i are our buddies like
we're friends
and we we speak in an interview on
siriusxm's the howard stern show
the actress said she and pitt are
buddies and there's no awkwardness in
the relationship
we speak and and there's no
there's there's no oddness or at
all except for everyone that probably
watched it and was wanting there to be
or a student yeah i would
be i was i was like i didn't think you
would be a part of that i don't know
and there you were it was classy i know
and there we are
that's great well i don't know and it
was for a great cause
for core fans couldn't get enough of the
chemistry between the former couple
during the virtual reunion
jen played linda and brad ended up
playing well
brad who just so happened to have a very
spicy scene together in the 1982 flick
hi brad you know how cute i always
thought you were
i think you're so sexy will you come to
me
the moment came after this reunion
between jen and brad at the 2020 sag
awards that went viral
i'll run into jen she's a good friend a
week later the actor opened up to e.t
about the huge fan reaction
what do you make of our reaction to the
big reunion backstage last week
at this edge i don't know i'm blissfully
naive and i'm gonna stay that way okay
you haven't been on the internet at all
of course the two were married from 2000
to 2005.
what do you make of all the
ridiculousness about you and
brad reuniting on all these carpets all
season long it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about
in may a source told et that fans won't
be seeing the two getting back together
quote there's nothing romantic there but
they are definitely aware that their
fans are constantly rooting for them to
get back together
and laugh about it together the sources
add that jen and brad sometimes like to
egg on the media frenzies surrounding
them in a playful way
the exes respect each other and think
each other are both widely talented and
hilarious as for her current love life
the actress who also remains on good
terms with her most recent ex-husband
justin thoreau
admitted in a recent interview with
people that she's open to falling in
love again
but quote absolutely will not try dating
apps to find a new partner that's a
no-brainer for me
jen insists she's more traditional when
it comes to romance saying quote
i'm going to just stick to the normal
ways of dating having someone ask you
out that's the way i would prefer it as
for whether she would be interested in
getting married again the 51 year old
actress says she wants to be with a
fantastic partner
who she can enjoy life with and have fun
but for now
jen is focusing on her work her friends
and her pets telling the mag that she's
in a really peaceful place
i literally think that every day like
wake up and feel very lucky